last talk of the day we're uh happy to
have vidya muthukumar who's going to be
telling us about her work on the
complexity of stochastic games
so i'll uh i'll let you take it away
thanks dylan for the introduction thanks
to the organizers for organizing this
really great workshop it's my pleasure
to be here
um so without further ado i'll tell you
a little bit about our very recent work
um characterizing the complexity of
infinite horizon general some stochastic
games
um to start off this uh is joint work
with yuji jin who's a final year grad
student at stanford and aaron sidford
um and without further ado i'd like to
start first by thanking the simons
institute um for creating the
environment that actually began this
collaboration in the first place um so a
lot of the ideas that i'm going to
present here today actually originated
at the theory of reinforcement learning
program in late 2020
i also want to mention that there must
be something nice in the air at simons
some of the results that i'm going to
talk about today were also discovered in
independent concurrent work by daskar
larkisgolovic and zhang
i believe noah is giving a talk on their
concurrent book tomorrow morning so if
you'd like to learn more about this area
um i also recommend you check out their
talk
okay
um
so as i mentioned the ideas for this
project started in early 2020 um and the
very first slide of my talk actually
directly coincides with the very first
slide of a talk that i gave back then
so as
during my time at simon's in late 2020 i
was interested in investigating
questions um in multi-agent
reinforcement learning
and my very introductory slide to a talk
i gave them introduced the setting of
general sam stochastic games
so over here we're describing stochastic
games in one of the simplest possible
settings in which you can study them
which is the tabular setting
and in this setting we have a finite
state and finite action space
and we're considering a general sum
environment
so
this strictly generalizes the single
agent mbp in the sense that now we have
multiple agents that is agent one to n
who can all take a simultaneous action
at a given sound and this joint sequence
of action play given by 81 to atm
dictates both the set of instantaneous
rewards that is admitted to each of the
agents and it also dictates the
probability transition going from sd to
st plus one now in this setting there
are a couple of facts that it is
relatively straightforward to see
the first is that a mixed nash
equilibrium of some type will always
exist
and more generally this stochastic game
model strictly generalizes the set of
all normal form games and the way in
which you can see that is you can see
that at a single stage the agents will
have to play some sort of nash
equilibrium of the simultaneous play
that they are playing at that level
and as a consequence of the strict
generalization
um it is relatively straightforward to
see that these general some stochastic
games are in fact ppid hard
and i believe this fact has also been
mentioned by a few other speakers at the
workshop today
so from this point of view things look
fairly pessimistic it's not possible to
compute nash equilibrium in this general
sum setting
so when i presented um the slide
assignments uh about a year ago
aaron sedford actually asked me a very
nice question and it turns out a pretty
deep question which is whether this
hardness of equilibrium computation
continues to hold under the
simplification where players take turns
in playing the game
so what i mean by that
is that now at a given round only one
agent is active and only one agent can
take an action so this is an
illustrative example of a turn-based
stochastic game also called the tbsg
where at state st
only player 1 is able to control that
state
so just as before all of the players
will receive a reward and in general
these reward functions can be completely
heterogeneous and different for all the
agents
but now the key difference is that only
a single agent is taking an action and
that single action dictates both the
instantaneous rewards and the transition
to the next stunt
and this may seem like a very
significant simplification of the markov
game structure but it's worth noting
that tbsgs are pretty common in the
setting of multi-agent rl and if you
think about a lot of examples of
computer game thing the players do
indeed take turns from them
who decides on who should
who decides on
how the agents should take turns
is it a random is it a random sort of a
selection
um so in the model i'm going to consider
today the identity of the player
controlling the stage would depend on
the state of the game and i'm going to
get to this a bit more formally a few
slides from now
but um in this example for example you
have a mapping
state to control that's iost here
but i'll i'll say this a little bit more
quickly
yeah the identity of the controlling
player is dependent on the state in
which the name is at
so it's it's it's a deterministic
mapping from state to control
okay
so um at a high level what you can see
from this turn based structure is that
the trivial reason for ppad hardness no
longer exists
and
in general this does not strictly
generalize normal farm games anymore
so the very natural question that comes
up in this context is whether it in fact
remains hard to compute a nash
equilibrium of a turn-based stochastic
game and this fundamental question forms
the backbone of our talk today
so um
this question actually turns out to be a
pretty intriguing one to answer and the
reason is because at the outset it seems
like the answer could really go either
way
so starting off with some possible
evidence for polynomial time
computability
it actually turns out to be not very
difficult to show that a non-stationary
nash equilibrium is in fact computable
in polynomial time
and
this polynomial time computability has
several interesting implications for
learning such equilibrium concepts and
this actually follows from some recent
work and i believe she talked about a
subset of this recent work in the
morning
so just to see a little bit about why a
non-stationary equilibrium becomes
relatively easy to compute
we can actually walk through one step of
the backward induction principle
so let us say that we want to understand
what the equilibrium policy needs to
look like at round t
what we can say is that given access to
the equilibrium values after time t plus
1
because of the significant
simplification where only one agent is
active at a given round
the
equilibrium policy at round t
essentially boils down to a single agent
optimization problem so in our
illustrative example player 1 controls
the state st
and in this model player one is simply
going to maximize her value to go which
is given by the q function um at round t
of st and action a and this is simply
the instantaneous reward and then the
equilibrium value to go around t plus 1.
so this is simply a simplification of
the multi-agent backward induction
principle and what you see here is that
when you specialize to the turn-based
setting this boils down to a single
agent optimization problem
so this is one kind of instance that
shows you that this is a much much
simpler type of structure than the usual
simultaneous stochastic game
on the other hand it turns out to not be
very easy or obvious how to extract a
stationary solution concept from a
non-stationary one
and we can see this by now turning to
the infinite horizon setting where we
allow the game to play for infinite
rounds and consider a discounted model
and over here it actually turns out
that there's a fundamental
failure in the infinite horizon dynamic
programming principle for learning
stationary equilibria in fact um there's
a very very nice paper by martin zinke
which amy greenwald and michael littman
back in the 2000s that showed that
variance of value iteration and policy
iteration and the like will actually
cycle instead of converging to a
stationary solution concept
and in general it remains very very
unclear how we can extract a stationary
nash equilibrium from a non-stationary
one
so the fact that the evidence for
what could happen goes both ways leads
us to a very very natural question in
the context of stationary nash
equilibrium and this is the question of
what in fact is the complexity of
infinite horizon turn based general some
stochastic games if what we care about
are the stationary nash equilibrium
and in particular we will be interested
in understanding whether such equilibria
are computable in polynomial time or
whether these are instead intractable
a somewhat related a more subtle
question is what is the complexity of
simultaneous stochastic games
while as uh since these strictly
generalize the set of normal form games
we know that these are going to be ppad
hard
but um what we do not know is whether at
the outset stationary equilibrium
computation will be in ppad as well
so these are the two questions that are
going to form the backbone of my talk
today
um and with that here's a quick outline
of what i will be covering
so i'll start with a more formal
description of the basic setup
and i will then talk about a few
structural properties of stationary
equilibria in pbsg and simultaneous
stochastic games that were very central
to all of our results
i will then give you a concrete answer
to the complexity of stationary
equilibria in pbsgs
and at the end i want to spend a few
minutes talking about what i believe are
some very interesting future directions
so with that i'd like to yeah
application questions should you mention
our earlier results along with the
learning results
for the general's general sun markov
game is actually just the large
equipment for the term best
great so um without further ado let's
get into a more formal description of
the setup that we're going to be
studying today
so this is just uh our block diagram for
infinite horizon simultaneous stochastic
games um and henceforth i'm going to be
focusing on stationary strategies and
what i mean by that is that the policy
that agent one place is not going to be
allowed to be time ready
so in this context there's very compact
notation that we can set up for same as
g
so s here denotes i think it's getting a
bit cut off
so you can see there okay perfect
okay so s denotes the state space
n denotes our set of players and in
general this can be either smaller this
can be large
and just to keep things very gentle i'm
going to denote ais as the set of
available actions for player i at state
s
and because i'm restricting to
stationarity we can
kind of compactly represent the whole
strategy space in terms of
pi 1 to pi m which is simply the joint
stationary strategy that is taken by all
of the players
and just a shorthand this is standard
shorthand notation i'll denote p pi and
ri pi as the transition kernel and the
reward function induced by this joint
stationary strategy
so just to keep things uh concrete i'm
going to throughout this talk consider
the discounted model
although some of our results do extend
to the average reward case under certain
further assumptions
and i'm going to consider a discount
factor denoted by gamma which is
strictly less than one
so under this model the value function
of player i at an initial distribution q
that sorry that's a typo that should be
q
of the stationary policy is simply given
by the sum of the discounted rewards
where ri pi is as i've mentioned the
reward induced by the strategy pi and
the expectation here is both with
respect to the initial distribution
and the transition kernel that is
induced by the policy
and just to keep things in more game
theoretic notation i'm often going to
now refer to this as just ui of pi so
the utility function of player i
as a function of the stationary strategy
pi
so in this context we're going to define
a stationary nash equilibrium with
respect to all possible deviations of
the stationary nature
so what this means is that the strategy
pi star is a stationary nash equilibrium
if and only if for all values of phi and
all alternative stationary policies that
she could take
um she does not gain by more than
epsilon um by deviating from from the
current strategy
so just uh to be a little more detailed
about that this is essentially the
definition of an epsilon approximate
nash equilibrium
and there are other definitions of
approximate equilibrium that are related
in the literature but i'm going to be
focusing on the approximate nash
equilibrium today
so in this context we can also very
compactly talk about the turn-based
stochastic game setting
and
just to address a question that came up
a little bit earlier what this setting
does is it says that
for each state only one agent which is
given by this mapping ifs is active at a
given state
and for all other agents that are not
equal to ifs the set of actions
available to that agent at that state is
going to be a null set
so in this example we have st and ifsd
is equal to 1 and consequently only
agent 1 is active at that given block
but the value function definitions and
the definition of stationary nash
equilibrium remain exactly the same
so if there are any further questions
about the setup i'm happy to take them
here but i can also move on
okay great
so before i kind of get into the details
of what we address i also want to give a
very very high level aside into the ppid
complexity class and how you should
think about it
many people in the room who know about
more about ppid than me so you can also
defer to them
but i'm just going to give you a sense
of what ppad is and
what we mean when we say that it's
intractable
so the formal definition of ppad
consists of all problems that are
polynomial time reducible to a certain
type of combinatorial graph total search
problem called end of a line
and really the very important high level
thing to know about this class of
problems is that a solution is always
guaranteed to exist and this is part of
the so-called class of total search
problems and
the sense and and what this kind of
means in a certain sense is that the
p-pad class is easier than np but it is
still believed to be much harder than p
and typically for all practical purposes
we tend to think of the p-pad complexity
class as essentially intractable
so now that we have the basic problem
setting set up
something that i want to highlight for a
few moments is um what i think makes
this problem interesting
and a lot of it actually has to do with
restricting to considering stationary
strategies and stationary nash
equilibrium
and in this setting it turns out that a
twin challenge that arises when
considering equilibrium computation
problems is the one of non-linearity in
the utilities and this is purely a
consequence of restricting to stationary
nash equilibria
and also in the case of turn-based
stochastic games a significant type of
shared structure across the utility
functions of all the players
so starting with the case of
non-linearity there are a number of
different ways in which we can see that
this is going to make problems of
algorithms and computation challenging
to start off
note that when we consider stationary
strategies it is not it is well known
that the utility function of i of its
own policy pi i is going to be
non-convex in its own argument
and as a consequence of this at the
outset even membership of equilibrium
computation in ppad is not at the outset
completely clear
i also want to mention a little bit
about the types of existence proofs of
equilibria that we tend to have in these
settings
so in the zero-sum case it actually
turns out that the existence of
stationary equilibria follows via
a dynamic programming argument at the
infinite horizon setting
but in the general sum case like we have
already mentioned this dynamic
programming argument actually breaks
down
and if you actually go back and read the
oldest the earliest existence proofs for
sims g and tbst
these actually use a pretty complex
kakutani fixed point theorem based
argument and there's no existence proof
that directly uses brower's fixed point
so all of these
kind of suggest that there's a lot of
difficult structure in the utility
functions when we restrict to the
stationary case and this makes the
problem more challenging
and the second challenge that is kind of
intertwined with this one of
non-linearity but is a little bit
distinct in nature
is the one that there's a lot of shared
structure across utilities so if you
think about um like i sort of mentioned
at the beginning of the talk in this
tbsg setting the rewards are on are
received sequentially and not
simultaneously
and they don't directly interact with
one another
and in some sense the fact that you have
transitions and you're restricting to
stationary equilibria induces a type of
implicit simultaneity but nevertheless
there's a lot of shared structure across
the induced utility functions so we do
not have the type of freedom that you
have in for example a normal farm game
where you can change the utilities
completely arbitrarily
so there are a few challenges here
and for us they just made the problem
more interesting and richer to study
and what i'm going to do for the rest of
the talk is say a little bit about how
we were able to address both of these
challenges
yeah good question um in that challenge
uh
first part you had a non-convexity thing
um so equilibria are not guaranteed to
exist when you have non-complexity so
i'm guessing i'm missing something
why like if it's not existing how is it
so that is a great question so like i
mentioned um it is known that the
equilibria are guaranteed to exist
um and these are specialized proofs to
the case of stochastic games um what i'm
going to talk about in just a little bit
is that we were able to identify a
special type of structure that gathered
these existing
um so i'd like to now say a little bit
about um so so in some sense i've said a
lot about how there was there seems to
be a lot of complex structure in the
utilities for stochastic case
and now we are going to see that maybe
that's not quite the case there's
actually a lot of simpler structure that
we were able to identify that helps us
to address many of the questions that i
have faced
so the basic property that we were able
to show in the case of discounted
infinite horizon stochastic games
is a certain type of pseudo-linear
property on the utilities when a
player's policy is only allowed to
change at one state
so more formally what i've done here is
i've fixed a player i and i've picked a
particular state
and i've considered two policies that
only change their prescription at one
state
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to consider linear combinations of these
policies note that in general these can
be stochastic and i'm denoting this as
pi theta just as shorthand
and in this context what the
pseudo-linear property essentially says
is that the utility function going from
pi 0 to pi 1
always has a bounded slope
and the figure over here essentially
shows that our utility function is in
some sense linear up to multiplicative
factors
so note that if you had exact linearity
you would simply be coinciding with the
deadline over here our pseudo-linear
property and also note that this is
not at odds with non-convexity this is
of course not a non-convex this is of
course not a convex or a concave
function
but it is nevertheless very very strong
structure
so i'll say a little bit about some nice
implications of this type of structure
um the first one is that as a direct
consequence of this we have this type of
coordinate wise monotonicity and you
actually see that visually from the
figure here you see that this purple
curve is upper and lower bounded by the
pi zero and pi one
and it actually turns out that there are
traditional proofs in the literature
that imply a completely elementary proof
of existence of nash equilibrium just
following from this type of property
holding for any two pairs of such
policies
so the sum of this is that we have a
much more elementary proof of existence
and as we're now going to see we can
also turn this proof of existence into
explicit algorithms
i guess what i'm going to say is that
you can actually uh you can actually get
an existing proof to a grower function
um by using this property
okay
so um what it actually also turns out we
can do here um is
basically use the special structure to
imply that an approximate fixed point of
nash's brower function um so this is the
original brower function that is used to
show membership of normal farm games in
ppid
and that was designed traditionally for
these linear utilities um we were able
to show that this type of proof idea
also works for this type of linearity up
to multiplicative factors i mean some of
the details get more complex but the
high level proof structure is quite
similar
and what all of this in the end implies
is that the problem of equilibrium
computation of stochastic games is not
only ppad hard but also lies in ppad
for
n players for
s states for a actions and a
polynomially bounded discount factor
so all i mean by that is that 1 over 1
minus gamma is allowed to polynomially
grow in the state space size and the
action space size
so that's kind of a nice implication
that we get out of this special
structure
and it also turns out although i'm not
going to talk about this in a lot of
detail
that this pseudo-linear property is also
useful on the flip side if we want to
understand necessary conditions for a
strategy to be an approximate nash
equilibrium again not going to talk
about that in detail but um
that is turns out to come in handy for
some of our other results as well
so um i'll try and say a little bit uh
about i'm just going to say at a high
level how we were able to show this type
of pseudo-linear structure
and the main kind of observation was
that if we do fix a player i and two
policies
and
fix the other players policies as well
um the system reduces to a type of two
policy markup reward process
where only one state has two actions and
every other state has only one action
so just to see a kind of diagram
depiction of such a two policy mvp
what you see here is that state one is
only has two actions available to it and
all the other states have only one type
of trivial action so this is a very very
simple type of mdp that we can consider
and it actually turns out that in this
context um it suffices in a certain
sense to show this pseudo-linear
property under this very very elementary
type of two policy mdp
and it actually turns out that the
values are still not going to be convex
in their argument
but you can still show this type of
approximate pseudo-linear property and
i'm not going to get into the details of
how we were able to show this
but maybe what i'll say is that the
proof was in some sense surprisingly
simple um you just look at a kind of
explicit formula and you use the fact
that your updates are going to be like a
rank 1 matrix
and there's certain interpretations to
these factors in terms of understanding
the discount state visitation
frequencies so don't worry if you don't
understand any of that um i didn't get
into much detail but i'm happy to talk
more about it offline
um and just to really concretize that
mapping a little bit more um
what we see is that
the basically if we have fixed the other
player and the other states
and we're considering two candidate
policies that vary only at one state
this is clearly can be mapped to a
two-action mdp and as a direct corollary
of that we get this type of
pseudo-linear property out of all of
this
so just to summarize the progress we've
made so far
um what we have so far seen is that the
problem of simultaneous stochastic games
nash equilibrium computation is not only
ppid heart it is also in ppad
so this brings us to our next question
given all of the special structure that
i have highlighted in the case of
turn-based stochastic games
does stationary equilibrium computation
remain ppid hard or does it become
polynomial time
and this is the next and last question
that i'm going to address today
[Music]
so in the
uh thing that you presented you assume
pseudo-linearity to get that result so
how does that apply to
general some stochastic marker games oh
yeah that's a great question um so
like you said we have only considered
the pseudo-linearity properties on
policies that change at a single state
it turns out that what you can do is you
can show that to evaluate whether a
given policy is a nash equilibrium it
suffices to consider coordinate by
deviations alone
and that's kind of that was the second
piece that would be that we that we used
yeah that's a great festival i i didn't
really get into that
uh
so i guess what i'm saying is that if
you look at uh let's say you have chi
square i and phi standard psi
see
an equilibrium
um it only suffices to consider
deviations of the form of pipeline by s
and pi
so it only suffices repeats for all
excellence
because i guess you're saying it's a
bounded slope thing but i guess
so like it seems like there's something
more happening there's a relationship
between the two
yeah that's that's a good question um
what i would say is it's kind of like a
lipsticks and an anti-lip [ __ ] kind of
statement at the same time
um yeah it's kind of like yeah it's kind
of saying that the slope is bound upper
and lower yeah so it's a little bit more
than obvious
can you just do this
that is a good question um it is
definitely possible um but note that you
would have to consider these you can
only this this property only holds if
you change the policy in a single state
so if you change the policy at more than
one state you can actually come up with
counter examples
and you get this
how much more time do i have done maybe
15 minutes or so
okay so now we're going to adjust the
final remaining question from this top
which is whether tpsgs are polynomial
time or ppad hard
unfortunately just to burst everyone's
bubble um
we end up showing that tbsgs are in fact
intractable
despite all of the nice structure that
we hinted at the problem remains hard
more formally for any discount factor
that is sufficiently large greater than
one half and a sufficiently small
constant computing approximate nash
equilibrium turns out to be worst case
hard in the number of states
so what this implies at a high level is
a fundamental separation between the
complexity of non-stationary and
stationary nash equilibria these were
polynomial time but these are
intractable
and there's actually a nice connection
which i think i have to credit costas
for because i think he mentioned this at
some point in january that um this kind
of intractability implies the intact
ability of simultaneous stochastic gains
course correlated equilibria and this is
because in some sense the nash
equilibrium in a turn-based game is a
special case
so this is a somewhat non-standard uh
hardness result in the context of
algorithmic game theory
uh just a few more details about the
hard instances that we construct and i'm
going to say a little more in a few
minutes about exactly what we did
um but i want to say that our hard
institutions can be expressed either as
an n player a stochastic game
where each player receives a non-zero
reward at at most four states so it's an
n player game but a very very structured
type of and player game
or we can we also realize later that we
can also make our constructions work out
of the box
for um a six-player turn-based game so
this is an alternative formulation where
we have a constant number of players but
arbitrary reward structure
um finally i want to mention that the
independent concurrent work by desker
luck is at all was able to show that
even two player pbsds are hard so in a
very strong sense all of the answers we
have to this problem are now negative
you have constant states out of
curiosity your results
you have also number of states
and i'm trying to see the case of
constant states
[Laughter]
you can sort of say in general the
number of players is at most the number
of states
um
but
this can sometimes be a lot smaller it
can be um two for example
uh so i'm gonna try and say a little bit
about the deduction i also asked about
the so the ppa department so not part
number is in there now players or
it's finally
okay so i'm gonna try and say a little
bit about um what it takes to prove a
hardness result like this
and the basic idea that we used was to
reduce to a class of problems that is
well known to be ppad hard
so this is the class of arithmetic
circuits satisfiability problems and the
history of this problem actually goes uh
way back in complexity theory
the basic idea is that is kind of
encapsulated in this diagram here and
the input consists of a circuit
of uh of variables x1 x2 x3 up to x6
and as output we need to have an
approximately satisfying assignment of
all of these uh real valued variables
so
the
the red kind of diagonal uh blocks
represent um arithmetic gates for
example the equality gate
this like kind of forces x2 to be
approximately equal to x1 and the
additive gate requires x4 to be
approximately equal to x1 plus x3
and the multiplicative gate requires x5
to be approximately equal to alpha
multiplied by x4
so there are a number of satisfiability
operations we can include here as a
technical detail note that the circuit
may in fact contain cycles so it's not
just a type of tree
so um a very kind of important result
that we fundamentally leverage to show
our hardness result goes to avr
dzlubenstein who i think proved this in
1718
uh who showed that this type of circuit
satisfiability problem is in fact ppad
hard
for a sufficiently small constant given
by epsilon
and basically what we're going to do is
we're going to reduce equilibrium
computation in tbsgs to this type of
generalized circuit problem
and the way we are going to do that is
by identifying certain types of tbsgs
such that a necessary condition for the
equilibrium of that tbsg will implement
this type of gadget and this is commonly
called the game gadget at a high level
this is also the approach taken to show
hardness and intractability for normal
farm games and here we're going to
follow the strategy for the case of
tbsgs
so
what i want to do before actually saying
a bit about how we do this for the case
of tbsgs is give a brief review of how
this is typically done for the case of
normal foam case
and in this context i'm going to review
one of the initial steps for showing
interactability of a related class of
games called an end player graphical
game
and in this setting the vertices of a
graph model players and directed edges
represent influences on utilities so in
this example there are three players
given by in aux and out
and the edges represent how the players
interact with one another so in this
example for example ox plays a normal
farm game within and out and out plays a
normal farm game with ox and this is
actually a very very simple game where
each of the three players only has two
actions given by zero and one
and in this notation i'm going to denote
p out as the probability that outplays
action one and keep that similar
notation for n
so the basic building block that i want
to illustrate is the fund following
fundamental fact
it is possible to set up a game like
this and define utility tables for the
out and the ox players
such that
for any nash equilibrium of this
graphical game we must have this
approximate equality constraint so this
is what i mean when i say that a game
gadget implements an arithmetic gate of
a certain type
so i'll say a bit about how we show this
i mean not not how we show this how
tasker luck is at all in chen dang and
tank show this
um
so the basic idea is somewhat two-fold
it is possible to construct a normal
farm game for the auxiliary player
such that its utility for zero follows p
in and its utility for one follows p out
and the other piece of this uh kind of
reduction involves having out piece
somewhat anti-coordinated with clear aux
so one can actually use this and go
through a type of proof by contradiction
argument so remember we need to show
that any nash equilibrium necessitates p
out to be approximately equal to p n
and we assume instead that p out is much
much smaller than p n and we're going to
contradict the statement
so assuming this
reading the utility table of ox then
tells us that ox will mostly want to
play action zero just because p n is
much larger than p out and then because
of the anti-coordination principle out
will mostly want to play action one
and now note that we have p out much
less than p n and if p out is going to
be close to one this is a fundamental
contradiction with the statement that we
have set up
so this is the kind of qualitative
structure and but the proof i've
actually presented here is exactly
quantitative this is exactly the type of
utility structure that we really want
so we took inspiration from this type of
graphical game reduction approach and we
wanted to see whether we could make
similar ideas work for the case of tbsg
and some of the ideas actually do
transfer over in the sense that it is
possible to make a high-level connection
where the vertices of the graph
represent states and their directed
edges represent deterministic
transitions
but there are some kind of subtle
differences between the two classes
simply because now the edges don't just
represent local connections between
players but they also represent a more
global type of structure between all of
the players
so as an example over here what you can
see is that for example aux is
influenced both by in and out
but
out is going to actually now be
influenced by both of the players
because it could for example transit
here and then transit all the way here
and now we're going to see that this is
going to fundamentally change some
aspects of our construction
so recall that we wanted this two-fold
utility property where we want ox to
follow in and out under these respective
pure strategies and then we want out an
aux to be in some sense anti-coordinated
and it turns out that there are many
qualitative ways of making this idea
work but getting the details to work is
a lot harder
and in particular what we our initial
attempt at this at doing this actually
did not work in a certain sense
and there are kind of two fundamental
flaws in our initial construction
um the first one was that in our initial
attempts to do this
we did not get this property of the
utilities being linear like we could not
directly compare p and p out in the way
that i was describing and it actually
turns out that
pseudolineality is not sufficient to be
able to
make this work
a more fundamental flaw is that even
this linear structure over here is not
robust to subsequent connections between
other states so in some sense it is not
sufficient to implement an equality gate
in isolation we need to be able to then
connect this with other gates in the
arithmetic circuit to make things work
so this was essentially a buggy
construction and i illustrated it to
highlight a few challenges that come up
when designing this
so our basic fix that simultaneously
addressed both of these issues
was to create these kind of long paths
at the each of the output states of a
particular gadget
and the intuitive ideas like what you're
kind of doing is you're increasing the
effective distance between the output
state and the other states and what this
does in some sense is it induces
locality of the type that we really
wanted in the case of a graphical game
and it also turns out
that this induces a type of approximate
linearity now up to additive factors and
not just multiplicative factors
so a lot of details here that i didn't
get to but at a high level this approach
fixes some of the fundamental flaws that
i described earlier
and ultimately from this we are able to
really obtain that the equality
operation that we wanted from all of
this
so um some details that i completely
omitted in all of this
a lot of this i talked about the
implementation of an exact match and it
turns out to go to an approximate nash
we use the pseudo-linearity property
that we obtained many times
i did not talk about the construction of
the other gates other than equality i
only wanted to illustrate one and
finally i only kind of sketched out the
details of combining gadgets there's
some details involved in actually making
that work
so uh just to wrap up because
i know people want to go to the
reception
so we have essentially a complete
complexity characterization
now for the case of stationary nash
equilibrium and the two main things i
want to highlight here is that
stationary equilibria in the case of
simultaneous games is no harder than
non-stationary equilibria the problem
remains in ppad
but unfortunately for the case of tbsg
there is a fundamental separation
between the non-stationary case and the
stationary case
so this paints a very customistic
picture we have a bunch of intactability
results over here
something i didn't talk about is that in
certain cases we were able to show
polynomial time results
but we had to make a pretty strong
assumption where each of the n players
receives a non-negative reward only at
their own state so i didn't talk about
this in detail but i'm happy to talk
about it offline so this is we
identified one case where you can get
polynomial time even for stationary
equilibrium
um since this question came up i'll also
add that we have a relatively simple
algorithm to show that we can compute
stationary equilibria in polynomial time
of the number of actions per state so if
you had an mdp with maybe two or three
states but a very large number of
actions then tbsgs are much much easier
um and finally i mostly talked about
discounted models but we do have
extensions to average reward models and
i just want to advertise this paper by
uga and iron where they show these
gentle
mappings between average reward and
discounted
games
cool so um i want to say a bit about
open problems very quickly because i
think that's really where all the fun
stuff is
i think there's a sense in which our
heart instances are very contrived i
think it would be very nice to identify
other instances where we get polynomial
time computability
um i think looking at alternative
solution concepts in between stationary
so maybe a little more complex in their
representation but also
simpler than non-stationary equilibrium
and one nice example isn't this paper by
zinkovic at all i think identifying
cyclic correlated equilibria and
computing these fast would be very
interesting
i think learning questions outside of
computation are interesting over here
and uh finally as a more technical point
our membership in ppid still assumed a
constant or a polynomially bounded
discount factor or equivalently a
polynomially bounded mixing time and
once we go beyond that i think
membership remains an open question
so with that
thank you all for listening and for the
nice questions
cool that was a great talk
uh let's see do we have any uh questions
oh it looks like uh okay we have a few
i'll go to chi first
yep
i will also ask about the just the upper
bounds you mentioned in the very end
like you said when you have a fixed like
small number of states and but you can't
have point number in a i'm wondering for
that kind of scenario could you also do
polynomial in terms of number of agents
and also the discounted factor like 1
over 1 minus gamma oh yeah that's a yeah
great question um
we do not get polynomial you cannot get
polynomial in the number of players so
it okay yeah so you have to assume a
constant oh wait the number of players
is at most the number of states so if
you have a constant number of states you
automatically have a constant number of
players no i mean like if you have small
number of states but you have a lot of
player
so that okay so in the turn-based
setting that that setting will not arise
because um oh that cannot happen okay
but how about the
yeah how about the
discount factor like uh if
if one is is it also polynomial in one
over one minus gamma i have to check but
i think we have an exponential
dependence like the basic idea is that
even even if final state is small like
two you still have exponential
dependence on her i believe so but uh so
the basic ideas that we search
am i wrong am i missing something i
could be misremembering
i remember just it's like
i think
polynomially where the polynomial
depends on the number of states would be
my first thought
yeah i i think there's a subtlety
because basically what the algorithm
does is it searches over all possible
equilibrium values and then it uses the
fact that the development step is like
like you can you can write it in your
program that's the algorithm in a
nutshell
um
i think searching over the value spaces
where there may be another dependence of
the discount factor
um but again
but yeah
let's just let's talk about it so
understand character so basically you're
saying
paranoia is down but
other stuff is also not very clear it's
because part obviously it's not entirely
clear but yeah let's uh
that sounds good
[Music]
question one follow-up
without that you can get a linear
program instead of
a non-linear program it is because that
it is the
turn-based
i for example remember that someone
the zero sum case of
mdp
uh
of the classical stochastic game yeah
exactly yes sir
supplies one
has a non-linear program in order to
describe it so how did you get the
linear is it crucial that you have
turn-based ah okay so it's a linear
program under a very strong assumption
which is that you know the equilibrium
values
okay yeah if you did not and and what it
kind of says in interpret another way is
that the hardness of the problem is
related to finding the equal finding a
candidate equilibrium value and the
second question is can you say just one
more sentence about the membership
results that they are open
again
so um our results
essentially get a membership that is
ppad when the problem size is given by
n times s times a
um over 1 minus gamma
so if we had a situation
where um so think of a situation where
maybe gamma is 1 minus 1 over exp
s or a or something like that
then um the problem sizes like basically
uh there are certain there may be
certain interesting average reward
processes where the mapping to a
discount factor is not necessarily
polynomially bounded but maybe these are
still in ppid and this actually
encapsulates certain very interesting
regimes for the zero-sum case as well
thank you
yes i constrained that from all from all
states you can go to all states with
some lower bound probability
uh would that bypass your hardness
so the to understand you're saying if
you start so you're saying that you have
a full support on the transition
probability distribution yeah that's a
good question um our hardness
constructions do not satisfy that
property they're very deterministic i
think it is possible you could get a
polynomial time algorithm
but it's open
i doubt it right i mean you can put some
junk rewards that you can have
everything connected it's not like junk
rewards received by everybody
that's an irrelevant component of what
you do
misunderstanding but along with saying
as long as the jump probability is like
below the effective horizon induced by
the discount factor it doesn't really
affect anything oh yeah
so as long as you jump like lower
probability than the the effective
horizon i think even you can have uh i
guess it depends on your equation but
like
you can have
everything being connected
sure but but that but that's a trivial
part of the like you know no matter what
you like no matter what you do you
transition randomly everywhere you get
some
face reward
but then the real stuff happens in the
remaining probability
where you embed this construction right
so
i doubt that this will save you but uh
you see what i'm saying like you can
have
transitions and reward everybody receive
rewards
that's why i'm saying the lazy one if
you just said it to be lower that you
can take whatever the reduction is
instead of to be lower than the horizon
that affects everything well your
argument says that there is some
threshold where i hope that maybe it's
i see the merit in both your arguments
in that case i don't know for sure
you get something like exponential in
like one over whatever this like mean
probability is because like the one over
probability is gonna have to scale with
the number of states right the way
you're setting it up
but i think that uh for any constant it
doesn't have to do with i mean
i think you can get the same parameters
i guess the approximation
would decrease
[Music]
yeah but still to start thinking
no
i'm going to do the horizon
uh were there any more questions
um i was wondering if you want if you
were to define uh like a model of a
stochastic sequential game
would that be equivalent to your
turn-based markup game or is that a
different
yeah that's thing
that's a good uh question
um it would be a it would be i guess
that what i would say is the turn
basically was a special choice of the
stochastic sequential game um because
you can in general have information set
so these can be
yeah there's no more questions uh maybe
we can stop there and uh go to the
reception
i think the reception is uh out here so
yeah thanks for coming and uh yeah i
hope to see everyone back tomorrow and
just one more reminder uh to sign up for
the open problem session tomorrow
afternoon
oh yeah and of course let's give video
one more round of applause
[Applause]